so how would we use a service to our
application fortunately we've already
done most of the work we have a content
provider with the content notifier that
will notify our content observers our
fetchweathertask already runs completely
independently of our UI code on us now
we can make use of that intent service
that rato mentioned earlier with just a
few small changes we can get our code
working with an intent service instead
of with our fetchweathertask to start
let's create a new package for our
service then we'll add a new Java class
in that package that extends intent
service we hit ctrl I to once again add
the required abstract method and ctrl o
in order to add the constructor since
the service is an Android component you
guessed it it needs to be in the
manifest ok let's do this let's finish
implementing the sunshine service and
call it from forecastfragment
you can start a service using an intent
with the start service method it will
help to remember how to use explicit
intents